einreise restriktionen also im grunde
ein einreiseverbot bis auf ganz ganz
wenige ausnahmen erlassen das muss durch
die mitgliedsstaaten umgesetzt werden
das soll für 30 tage gelten
und deutschland wird das sofort umsetzen
das ist die aufgabe des
bundesinnenministeriums in
zusammenarbeit mit dem auswärtigen amt
das wird also erfolgen sodass zudem zu
der reisewarnung die wir heute
ausgesprochen haben die der
bundesaußenminister heiko maas
ausgesprochen hat jetzt noch diese
einreise restriktion bestehen wird und
wir unterstützen und freuen uns sehr
über den vorschlag die der den kosten
kommissionen gemacht hat es gibt einige
wenige länder die kleine ausnahmen
machen zum beispiel für andorra
aber ansonsten haben sich alle
mitgliedsstaaten einverstanden erklärt
dass unmittelbar und sehr schnell
umzusetzen
zweitens haben wir die leitlinien
begrüßt sie die kommission gemacht hat
zum grenzmanagement innerhalb der
europäischen union
hier habe ich von meiner seite aus sehr
stark betont dass zur erhaltung der
funktionsfähigkeit des binnenmarktes es
notwendig sein muss dass der freie fluss
der güter und waren gewährleistet ist
wir haben da einige schwierigkeiten im
augenblick und alle mitgliedstaaten
haben aber darauf sind darauf
eingegangen und haben gesagt sie werden
sich bemühen die wartezeiten an den
grenzen auch zu minimieren und die
entsprechenden technischen
voraussetzungen zum beispiel spezielle
bus autobahnspuren dafür zu finden und
das war sehr wichtig dass wir diesen
punkt auch diskutiert haben genauso wie
wir natürlich darauf setzen dass es
möglich sein muss dass der freie die
freie beweglichkeit der pendler auch
gewährleistet wird das ist zum beispiel
der französischen grenze deutschen
luxemburgischen grenze wird das recht
gut gehandhabt
an anderen stellen ist es hier noch
schwieriger insbesondere wenn es auch um
beschäftigte geht die nur für eine zeit
in deutschland arbeiten und zum beispiel
von bulgarien und rumänien ungarn oder
andere länder durch reisen müssen
hier wird sicherlich noch weiter daran
gearbeitet werden
drittens haben wir die beschlüsse der
euro gruppe gestern begrüßt und haben
noch einmal deutlich gemacht dass haben
eigentlich alle gesagt dass wir mit
natürlich ernsten sehr ernsten
konsequenzen für unsere wirtschaft
rechnen müssen
umso wichtiger ist für mich der freie
fluss der waren denn unser europäischer
binnenmarkt ist ja darauf ausgerichtet
dass wir arbeitsteilige produktion in
den einzelnen mitgliedstaaten haben
können wenn ich nur an die
wertschöpfungsketten unserer
automobilindustrie denke dann hängt das
eben nicht nur von der
produktionskapazität in deutschland ab
sondern eben auch von der zulieferung
von bestimmten teilen aus anderen
mitgliedstaaten und wenn wir ein signal
senden wollen dass wir uns entschieden
gegen die wirtschaftlichen folgen
stemmen die sowieso auftreten werden
dann gehört für mich die
bewegungsfreiheit für güter und waren
ganz entscheidend dazu wir haben
außerdem uns verpflichtet eine
koordinierung bei der rückholung
gestrandeter in anführungsstrichen also
von bürgerinnen und bürgern aus der
europäischen union zu machen die
irgendwo außerhalb der europäischen
union sich aufhalten
und wir haben noch einmal über die
versorgung mit medizinischen gütern und
ausrüstung gesprochen
die kommission hat jetzt auf wunsch
vieler mitgliedsstaaten sammle
ausschreibungen vorgenommen für
bestimmte medizinische güter das ist
sehr begrüßt worden
und ich begrüße auch sehr dass die
europäische kommission vorgeschlagen hat
das wir exportrestriktionen in für
lieferungen von medizinischen gütern und
ausrüstung für länder außerhalb der eu
haben
und deutschland wird koordiniert mit den
anderen mitgliedstaaten die auch solche
exportrestriktionen für sich
verabschiedet haben das dann sofort
aufheben wenn auch die anderen länder
dieses aufheben es gibt noch einige
mitgliedstaaten die auch solche
regelungen haben das war also die
tagesordnung die wir heute hatten
überall natürlich in vorderster linie
der schutz der bürgerinnen und bürger
der medizinischen versorgung der
bürgerinnen und bürger aber natürlich
auch dem bestreben die wirtschaftlichen
folgen so weit zu minimieren dass wir
eben damit auch wirklich gut umgehen
können eine große bereitschaft was
notwendig ist zu tun das ist von allen
bestätigt worden und insofern ist
deutschland da auch in einem guten
konzert wir haben dann davor eine
video-konferenz gehabt zwischen dem
präsidenten erdogan präsident ma con
boris johnson und mir dort haben wir
über die situation in syrien gesprochen
und ich glaube es war ein sehr
nützliches gespräch das ging einmal um
die humanitäre situation in idlib und
die möglichkeiten hier zu helfen
da deutschland hat 25 plus 100 millionen
euro zur verfügung gestellt für die
humanitäre hilfe
das muss nur jetzt schnell zu den
menschen gelangen wir haben natürlich
begrüßt dass es jetzt einen temporären
waffenstillstand gibt und der türkische
präsident hat uns über die gemeinsamen
patrouillen auch entlang dieser eine
verkehrsader im 4
in der nähe von edith berichtet aber wir
haben uns natürlich auch dafür
eingesetzt den politischen prozess in
syrien
trotzdem in viel breiterer weise
fortzuführen und wir haben über die nato
gesprochen
der türkische präsident hat noch einmal
betont dass er mitglied der nato sein
möchte wir haben dies auch bekräftigt
und begrüßt und umso notwendiger ist es
gegebenenfalls auch politische
differenzen immer wieder
auszudiskutieren dafür war heute eine
gute gelegenheit wir haben auch über das
thema der migration gesprochen
allerdings haben heute gespräche
stattgefunden zwischen dem türkischen
außenminister davutoglu und dem hohen
beauftragten
herrn borel wir sind jetzt nicht die
verhandlungsführer in diesem sinne haben
uns aber eindeutig für das eu türkei
abkommen ausgesprochen haben auch die
bereitschaft gezeigt gegebenenfalls mehr
finanzielle hilfen zu leisten aber auch
die anderen punkte zum beispiel
gespräche über die zollunion mit der
türkei nicht aus dem auge zu verlieren
insofern war das eine wichtige
video-konferenz die auch stattgefunden
hat unter den gegebenen bedingungen
sonst wären wir heute nach istanbul
gereist aber es war besser als wenn wir
uns gar nicht getroffen hätten
das sind die punkte über die ich sie
informieren wollte europa also
entschlossen bei allen unterschiedlichen
nationalen maßnahmen dieser krise
gemeinsam zu begegnen und das notwendige
zu tun sowohl bei der medizinischen
bewältigung dieser krise als auch bei
der ökonomischen bewältigung die uns
natürlich auch noch sehr beschäftigen
wird das steht außer frage
aber ich glaube unsere nationalen
maßnahmen sind ein gutes beispiel dafür
wie wir agieren sollten
frau bundeskanzlerin einen an
nachfolgefrage an gestern sie hatten vor
der schalter gesagt dass sie hoffnungen
haben dass man wieder zu den regelungen
des schengen-raums zurückkehren kann
haben das eben noch mal betont sind sie
nach den gesprächen und
unterschiedlichen argumenten ihre eu
kollegen jetzt eigentlich optimistisch
oder pessimistisch dass das gelingen
kann und eine frage zu der hilfe mit
medizinischer ausrüstung ist darüber
geredet worden dass china mittlerweile
ganz offensiv spanien italien und
anderen eu ländern hilfe anbietet und
sicher einige beklagt haben dass es
diese solidarische hilfe innerhalb der
eu nicht gegeben hat naja also zum der
zweiten frage will ich sagen dass wir
china ja auch geholfen haben deutschland
hat china medizinische ausrüstung
geschickt und die europäische union hat
in erheblichem umfang china medizinische
ausrüstung geschickt das heißt auch
china hat damals darum gebeten dass
geholfen wird und ich sehe darin jetzt
eigentlich ein effekt der sozusagen auch
umgekehrt gilt es ist in einer solchen
ja wirklich nicht vorhersehbaren krise
doch auch nicht zu erwarten dass alles
im rahmen der europäischen union bereit
gestellt werden kann also ich finde das
ist reziprok und insofern auch freuen
wir uns darüber und die betroffenen
länder wahrscheinlich noch mehr darüber
hinaus zu den schengen regeln also die
schengen regeln lassen ausnahmen zu aus
bestimmten gründen das heißt diejenigen
die jetzt restriktionen machen bezüglich
des freien verkehrs von allen
bürgerinnen und bürgern handeln
entsprechend den schengen regeln die
frage ist wie gut ist das koordiniert
und die zweite frage ist wie kann das
was unbedingt gewährleistet sein muss
nämlich der warenverkehr ungestört auch
wirklich funktionieren
und hier haben wir eben zum teil sehr
lange wartezeiten oder eben auch die
länder die sozusagen andere länder
durchqueren müssen haben probleme
und darüber ist heute gesprochen worden
und da ist auch von allen seiten gesagt
worden dass man abhilfe schaffen will
aber all das was jetzt
stattfindet auch an der deutsch
französischen grenze an der
deutsch-luxemburgischen grenze
entspricht dem schengen code wenn man
das notifiziert und dann ermöglicht und
ich habe noch mal darauf hingewiesen
dass eben auch die bewegungsfreiheit für
die arbeitnehmer gewährleistet sein muss
weil wir uns darauf natürlich auch
verlassen der luxemburgische
premierminister hat noch mal darauf
hingewiesen dass 60 prozent seiner
angestellten im medizinischen im
krankenhausbereich im medizinischen
bereich menschen sind die pendeln und er
ist quasi darauf angewiesen wenn die
medizinische versorgung in luxemburg
funktionieren soll
und so ist es eben an vielen stellen
dass es doch eine sehr hohe abhängigkeit
gibt auch das saarland hat beim
medizinischen personal zum beispiel
starke abhängigkeiten von französischen
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmern und
deshalb bemühen wir uns ja auch dass das
reibungslos funktioniert frau
bundeskanzlerin sie hatten gestern wenn
ich es richtig in erinnerung habe an
oder in aussicht gestellt dass bei der
video konferenz der staats und
regierungschefs heute auch über die
situation der flüchtlinge in
griechenland gesprochen wird
ist das der fall gewesen und wenn ja mit
welchem ergebnis
es sind keine konkreten ergebnisse
darüber zu verzeichnen gewesen
der griechische ministerpräsidenten tat
noch mal auf die angespannte situation
hingewiesen ja maltesische
ministerpräsident auch aber beschlüsse
dazu sind nicht geführt worden
das wäre glaube ich oder muss auch noch
besser vorbereitet werden wenn man so
etwas machen will aber im raum steht ja
natürlich die rückholaktion die ist ja
auch von der kommission betrieben wurden
von mehreren ländern über unbegleitete
oder schwer kranke jugendliche die läuft
ja frau bundeskanzlerin es gibt
offensichtliche sorgen in der
bevölkerung dass das geld knapp werden
könnte
der korona krise können sie den menschen
diese sorgen nehmen
es gibt keinerlei anzeichen dafür und
der fluss oder dave die verfügbarkeit
von geld ist gewährleistet ich möchte
sowieso dazu aufrufen dass wir die
bevölkerung bitten sich an die
mitteilung zu halten die ihr offizieller
seite machen und nicht den vielen
gerüchten glauben zu schenken denn wir
haben viele davon in im umlauf leider
wir gehen tun alles um wirklich
transparent zu informieren
und deshalb ist dass es das
gegenstandslos was da an befürchtung ist
frau bundeskanzlerin offenbar hat heute
der italienische ministerpräsident sich
stark gemacht für eine krone fonds der
gespeist werden würde aus ungenutzten
mitteln des esm können sie dazu was
sagen würden sie so einen fonds
befürworten sie haben ja die letzten
tage schon über deutsche solidarität
auch bei eu finanzen gesprochen
also ist es heute von der diskussion der
finanzminister berichtet worden die
neben den nationalen aktivitäten auch
die frage diskutiert hat was kann
europäischer seitz passieren da hat die
kommission vorschläge gemacht und da ist
auch darüber gesprochen worden dass ob
die ib oder aber der esm in bestimmter
weise agieren kann
das sind erste diskussionen zu den sind
keine beschlüsse bei den finanzministern
gefasst worden und wir gehen davon aus
dass die finanzminister auf dieser ebene
weiter arbeiten das ist von einigen
staats und regierungschefs auch
angesprochen worden dass das so sein
soll und ich werde mit olaf scholz
darüber auch sprechen dass auch die
deutsche seite daran weiter teilnimmt
aber ergebnisse dazu gibt es nicht
dankeschön
bis demnächst